Thank you everyone for coming out.
I'm Nick Gillespie.
And this is the Reason
Speakeasy, which is a
monthly unscripted conversation
with outspoken defenders
of free thinking and heterodoxy in
an age of cancel culture and
groupthink.
But we couldn't get them.
So we have George Dawes Green.
Tonight's
guest is George Dawes Green, whose
new book is chilling, historically
charged murder mystery
called "Kingdoms of Savannah."
And it's a fantastic read.
I recommend everybody
get a copy and read it.
George is a singular voice in
American letters, I think it's
fair to say, and a unique raconteur
that we're going to hear from him.
You know, we're going to see that
whose own past includes stints
living in a cemetery and running
a company that sold clothes
made from rare hand-woven
fabrics from Guatemala.
So we'll talk a little bit about
your entrepreneurial past
as well as your kind of cultural
entrepreneurship.
Two of his previous novels, "The
Cave Man's Valentine and the Juror,"
were turned into movies, one
of them a very bad movie by his
his own reckoning.
So we'll talk a little bit about
that. And a third novel, Raven's
Drew rave reviews when it was
published in 2010.
He's also the founder of The Moth,
which is celebrating its 25th
anniversary right this year to
its quarter life crisis.
It sounds like people know The Moth.
It's a wildly acclaimed
and popular event show
where people tell stories and a
podcast that's really redefined
personal storytelling in the digital
age. And I want to talk with you
about that because it's really kind
of fascinating to use
modern technology to go back to a
kind of very old form of
storytelling in entertainment.
We're going to talk about George's
experiences on the frontier
of creative expression and the ways
particularly in which the past
doggedly informs the present,
whether in his native Georgia
or post-COVID, New York
City. So, George, thank you so much
for speaking to us.
Thank you, Nick, for having me.
All right. So let's start with the
Kingdoms of Savannah,
you know, in a way.
And it's it's you know, it's
hard. Like, I don't want to give
away too much of the plot because
it's a murder mystery and it's
a thriller and whatnot.
But I guess it's safe to say that in
many ways the main character is
the city of Savannah.
Can you you are not from Savannah.
That's not your hometown.
But you're familiar with Savannah.
But why is Savannah at the center
of of your novel?
Well, although I was.
I'm not from Savannah.
We we, um.
Bounced around Yankee
cities for years.
When I was a little boy.
My dad was editor
of weekly newspapers that kept going
belly up one after another.
And then finally, my mother,
who was George and insisted
that we go back to Georgia.
And so we settled in Brunswick,
which was about an hour to
the south of Savannah.
And so when I was about 11 or
12, as when mom started
to take me on,
drives up to what she called
our capital city.
Because we are eighth
generation Savannahan.
So we'd get
into her big
barge like Chevrolet
Bel Air,
and she'd always have some fancy
hat.
And then we sail
up Route 17
and spend the afternoons
at cousin's houses in Savannah
in these terribly stuffy
parlors.
And and then
I would become inculcated
with the traditions
of Savannah and the South,
then the stories that were
sort of hammered into my head.
And the other thing that mother
loved were seances.
And all of the cousins loved
seances.
My mother's name was Inez
and the cousins.
I there were about four cousins
who were also named Inez, there was
just this sort of gaggle of
of first cousins and
second cousins.
And they would sit around
in these parlors
and commune
with the dead.